sono a londra e sto per incontrare
chiara ferragni mandiamo per step prima
cosa cambio look per il super evento ghd
di stasera ok decisamente meglio vi
piace il vestito tranquilli per i
capelli ovviamente ci pensa giacca di ma
adesso devo correre se no libertà sono a
londra e sto per incontrare chiara
ferragni ma andiamo per step prima cosa
cambio look per il super evento ghd di
stasera ok decisamente meglio vi piace
il vestito tranquilli per i capelli
ovviamente ci pensa ghd ma adesso devo
correre se no libero tardi eccomi
davanti al grande magazzino più famoso
al mondo r venite con me la mitica soia
ha realizzato per me delle onde morbide
con la ghd platinum plus adoro questa
piega super sorpresa per voi il gh di
dell'acs kit set il regalo di natale
perfetto che ovviamente viene via con me
arrivate all'evento igiul abbiamo subito
brindato con un buon bicchiere di vino
ecco è arrivata chiara pazzesca come
sempre e soprattutto il rosso anche lei
tornata in albergo e stata davvero una
serata stupenda ora vi spiego perché